hello and welcome to the shaky siren
show were in this video we're going to
talk about NAD+ and how levels of NAD+
can alter the circadian rhythm and how
that changes on Aging and most of this
work comes from a recent cell paper that
used an ammonia and are as a supplement
for nad plus so this paper was published
in Molecular Cell just this week I think
and it's called energy plus control
circadian reprogramming three part to
nuclear translocation to counter aging
so we'll try and break this paper down
introduce what they did and what the
results were but firstly we need to talk
about what nad plus is and the circadian
rhythm so I've spoken about nad plus
quite a few times now on this channel
but just to reiterate nad plus is a key
factor and it's one of the most abundant
molecules in the human body and it has
also different functions in the body as
well but there are two main functions
that nad plus has firstly as a redox
coenzyme and secondly as a substrates of
nad plus conceiving enzymes and so you
could argue that energy pass is the most
important molecule in the body maybe
with the exception of ATP but without
either of them your dad's within around
30 seconds so that is nad plus what
about the circadian rhythm so the
circadian rhythm is a natural internal
process that regulates on our 24-hour x
go roughly the sleep/wake cycle and
other biological and physiological
processes so you can drought these
cycles clock of health I'm up on all the
different changes that happen in the
body at different times of day because
it's when it's most adaptive but
critical to this video is understanding
how this circadian rhythm this 24-hour
cycle is actually regulated and so there
are four key components of sleep it's
multiple components involved but these
are the four main ones and these are
clock beam are one creepy room and
periods or quite and what are you gonna
say and these are factors they couple
together say clock and beam our one bind
together and period and cryptochrome
bind together in reality it is a lot
more complicated than this before
this paper that we need to move now so
in this paper they try to look at the
influence of NAD+ levels on the
circadian rhythm and say what I talked
about in a previous video was kind of
the opposite because I talked about
energy past levels as an output of the
circadian rhythm so in this video
looking at the input
how does nad plus drive the circadian
rhythm and how this is reciprocal
relationship work so to understand this
we need to become a little bit more
familiar with these four components that
I just mentioned so in the day time
clock and be my one they bind to DNA
because they are transcription factors
and they up regulate the expression of
lots of different genes two of these
genes happen to be period and
cryptochrome and so period and
cryptochrome remain in the cytoplasm
until some signals enable their nuclear
transport where they interact with each
other and also clock and beam are one to
form this macro complex that represses
the activity of clock and beam are one
so this also represses the production
off now the period encrypts cream i'm so
eventually corrode and cryptochrome get
degraded and you kind of just repeat the
cycle because you remove that repressive
activity for this video I've highlighted
beam r1 and party because they're the
gratings that will come back to you so
why is this like alien clock so
important to understand well around 10%
of the mammalian transcriptome that is
genes that are expressed within the self
is rhythmically expressed and some of
these genes includes metabolic genes and
knowing this fact maybe it's not
surprising that clock disruption is
associated with metabolic disorders such
as obesity and it's also associated with
aging so what happens on aging is that
there seems to be a loss of this robust
rhythmic oscillations got a car on the
roughly 24 hour turns girl and this also
has an impact on the genes that are
going to be expressed and so you
effectively release this robust
oscillations as it gets sampling during
aging but the key thing is that this
the outputs so what else do we know
about aging well one observation is that
NAD+ levels decline as you age and
interestingly taking supplements such as
other men that can increase the levels
of NAD+ have been shown to extend
lifespan in yeast worms and mice and
also to protect against AIDS associated
declines in mitochondrial dysfunction
fiscal performance and the other factors
that I've listed out here
so if NAD+ levels the finest we age and
there's also a loss of robustness of the
circadian rhythm as we age and circadian
disruption is associated with metabolic
disorders which can be improved from
80-plus restoration what is the
connection between NAD+ and how was that
mediated potentially through circadian
reprogramming well technically the
answer is yes there is an impact but
what exactly did they do in this paper
to uncover this say before I forget to
say these studies were done in mice and
as we all know I am NOT the mouse so
what did they do well they had some mice
and they used an R which is nicotinamide
right besides which is one of these
precursors that increase levels of NAD+
that some people take a supplements and
they gave the supplement to the mice and
they did this for four months and also
they had a control but they just had
normal water
and what they saw was by supplementing
they read the liver circadian
transcriptome so the genes that are
expressed in the 24-hour pattern was
altered by the supplementation and there
was four different patterns of changes
that they saw so as I mentioned earlier
only around 10% of the transcriptome
shows oscillations and so when they saw
the effect of supplementation they saw
that some genes had lost the pattern
some genes had gained a circadian
fluctuation others had a phase shift and
other genes were unaffected from the
supplementation and so around 50% were
unaffected so around 50% of genes which
is a lot of genes strain an altered
expression pattern by supplementation so
the question is how house is happening
what is an ad
and one thing they were interested in is
looking at the beam upon binding as we
be my oneness that transcription factor
that binds DNA and regulate expression
say for these experiments they used mice
that were either normal in quotations or
they had loss of B mail button and this
time instead of using nicotinamide
website they used n MN or nicotinamide
Murray nucleotides and stay injected 500
milligrams per kilogram four hours per
for sample collection so this time it
wasn't like the four months its mother
an acute response to see what would
happen and say because this time it
wasn't a key response they wanted to
apply the na the nmn such that it could
increase nad plus when it's at its
lowest which is that a site gave a time
of six and Psyche every time six also
corresponds with the highest activity
levels of email button and say as I said
they injected them of Anna man and say
because it did this four hours before
they collected the samples they did this
hour as I gave time of T and then
collected the samples at psyche of time
six so once they had their samples they
examined B Melbourne finding in each
case and they saw that NAD+ drives
circadian transcription by stabilizing
the male one binding to DNA I'm sorry
this can help us and start trying
understand why we see such dramatic
changes in the transcriptome because
we're actually altering the binding of
one of the key proteins involved in the
process but how does the NAD+ connection
relate to female 1 binding what's going
on here so to cut a long story short the
authors found that search one is
necessary for the response to an
increase in
NAD+ levels and without cell one it
prevented the stabilization that they
saw with bhima one with the addition of
an ax men so what is that one so that
one is one member of the family of star
twins which is one of these NAD+
dependent enzymes and say sirtuins
and so one idea seed lasers and say if i
something
this means as ratings can get Talent
with different modifications one of
these are acetyl groups and someone just
effectively takes it off or music from
the protein and this will have an impact
on the preachings function it's no
PlayStation that structure and its
interactions and so in the study they
looked of what happens when they have
cells that don't have any SATs one and
what they saw was an increase in the
levels of nuclear patty and so party is
one of these proteins that repress the
Eternity of Bheema one say if I haven't
increased levels in the nucleus it
professedly make it more oppressive to
be my one activity so it's trying some
races together
I learnt very quick quite fast increased
energy plus levels can increase the
activity of sat.1 that depends on energy
plus it can then remove an acetyl group
from party and this summer alters its
location within the the south and auras
interactions but the main message is
that this repression of party enables
the increased ability of female one at
that causes the circadian reprogramming
so okay cool you see this reprogramming
or some of the genes but it was actually
a good thing well this was the last
thing that they looked at in the paper
so to assess this question they then
looked at the differences between
supplementation and the impacts on the
circadian rhythm and other metabolic
readouts in young and old mice so in
young my young mice they have higher nad
plus levels than in Odum eyes and say
the young mice the 10 months old the old
mice with 22 months old and both groups
were given oral and are for six months
and they assessed a number different
qualities such as the Beamer one
recruitment cellular oscillations
rhythmic respiration and lastly they
looked at their activity patterns as
well and so compared to the young mice
having the old mice with the addition of
nicotinamide websites they were able to
improve all of the inequalities that
they assess matching similar levels to
the young mice
so this paper effectively shade that in
mice part of the benefit from NAD+
restoration comes from improving the
robustness of the circadian rhythm so I
hope you've learned something and as
always thanks for listening